welcome to an introduction to biodiverse
farm ecosystems
creating a biodiverse farm ecosystem one
that supports microbial plant and animal
life
is a key farm element part of a
sustainable farming system that
considers conservation of natural
resources
farm economic sustainability and produce
safety
in the next few minutes you'll hear and
see an overview of the elements involved
in creating a biodiverse farm ecosystem
from a whole farm planting perspective a
biodiverse farm ecosystem brings
conservation food safety and cost
benefits to your farm
hedgerows riparian zones nesting boxes
and bat boxes
are all ways to encourage biodiversity
hedgerows and riparian zones or natural
areas along waterways
provide pollinators a diversity of
flowering plants all season long
and provide habitat for wildlife giving
the wildlife a place to be other than in
your fields
these areas can also serve as buffers
protecting growing areas or water
sources used for irrigation
from contamination by animal production
areas
according to the usda natural resource
conservation service
at least 44 species of birds use nesting
boxes
in our area bluebirds chickadees
flycatchers nut hatches
warblers swallows and wrens will all use
songbird houses
locating birdhouses and perches so that
droppings on produce are minimized
is critical to maintaining produce
safety simple mitigation strategies can
encourage birds to perch in the right
place
bats are another option that can help
reduce pressure from insect and nematode
pests the usda natural resource
conservation service reports that a
single little brown bat
the species that most often occupies bat
houses
can catch hundreds of mosquitoes an hour
a colony of 150 big brown bats can eat
19 million root worms a year
stink bugs leaf hoppers and cutworms are
among the other pests bats will eat
while the bats catch insects that may
cause you trouble an
insectary placed along your farm's edge
provides habitat for pollinators and
beneficial insects
much like a hedgerow by carefully
creating a biodiverse farm
you can balance the risks of attracting
more wildlife to your farm with the
benefits that wildlife may bring
the usda natural resource conservation
can provide financial assistance for the
implementation of conservation practices
through the environmental quality
incentives program
and the conservation stewardship program
nrcs and extension
can provide technical expertise to help
with creating a biodiverse farm
ecosystem
introducing biodiversity smart
implementation can improve conservation
of natural resources
while maintaining the safety of produce
you